Nashville has a new acting mayor this
morning after the city's previous mayor
pleaded guilty to felony theft and
resign megan berry stepped down
yesterday
as part of the guilty plea he comes
weeks after she confessed to an
extramarital affair with the former head
for security detail
mark Strassmann is in Nashville
Tennessee mark good morning good morning
this scandal has consumed Nashville for
the last month
ever since the whispers around City Hall
were confirmed by the married mayor
herself the first female mayor in city
history had a nearly two-year affair
with a married cop assigned to protect
her it has been the privilege of my
entire professional life I've had the
blessing and the opportunity to be your
mayor
Megan berry ignored shouted questions
from reporters Tuesday after the 54 year
old Democrat resigned as Nashville's
mayor
what is your conditional plea to the
charges down to probably guilty or not
guilty earlier in state court berry
pleaded guilty to theft of property
agreeing to repay the city $11,000 and
unlawful expenditures entering a similar
plea deal Robert Forrest the former head
of the mayor's security detail he agreed
to reimburse the city $45,000 he was
paid in overtime mr. Forrest you have
any comment Forrest resigned after berry
admitted to their affair January 31st
I'm very embarrassed I'm deeply ashamed
an investigation by CBS Nashville
affiliate W tvf discovered forests
overtime pay more than doubled while
working for berry as the pair traveled
the country and the world together a
state investigation revealed that nude
photos of a woman were taken by forest
police issued smartphone while he was
assigned to protect her Berry said if
the photos were of her they were taken
without her consent
was her continuing as mayor sustainable
not my opinion
Nashville Republican councilman Steve
Glover says the scandal surrounding
berry was trashing the city's reputation
today's move was the right thing to do
hopefully it will allow us now to say
hey come on in to Nashville come see us
we're Oh
for business Barry will serve three
years probation as part of her plea the
vice mayor David Braley will now become
the acting mayor of Nashville and the
Tennessee Bureau of Investigation which
dug up many of the damning details says
this case is now over
Gail all right thank you very much mark